[Musik]
im nordrheinwestfälischen kfeld soll
diese Sportanlage modernisiert und
vergrößert werden doch als man jetzt
losbauen will stellt die Stadt Fest der
aufwendig ausgearbeitete Masterplan
funktioniert nicht denn auf dem
Erweiterungsgelände daneben darf gar
kein Sportplatz gebaut werden hier muss
ein
Regenrückhaltebecken hin die jahrelange
Planung ist komplett für die
Tonne es gibt ja Architekten und Planer
die die sich die Pläne anschauen was ist
denn da überhaupt möglich was kann denn
gebaut werden und da scheint man ja
irgendwas übersehen zu haben und kann
ich nicht so ganz nachvollziehen schon
eine peinliche Aktion nach zwei Jahren
festzustellen dass die Pläne gar nicht
so umsetzbar sind im Jahr 2022 legt die
Stadt ein 23 Millionen Euro Programm für
die Modernisierung ihrer Sportstätten
auf der neue Sportpark sprödental soll
laut Stadt ein Leuchtturmprojekt werden
ein wahres Schmuckstück aber beim Planen
des Schmuckstücks scheint niemand in den
Flächennutzungsplan geschaut zu haben
dort steht ausdrücklich hier muss ein
Regenrückhaltebecken hin deshalb wird
die sportparkplanung jetzt
eingedampft die neue 400 m Laufbahn das
Herzstück der Anlage wird ersatzlos
gestrichen hierfür ist nun kein Platz
mehr es ist ja nicht einer der an so
einem Projekt arbeitet es wird ja
wahrscheinlich ein ganzes Team sein
zumal im Vorfeld ja auch die ganze
Bürgerbeteiligung gelaufen ist es sind
Pläne offenelegt worden man hätte ja
viel viel gründlicher recherchieren
müssen ja ich meine die Planung ist
schon miserabel aber man muss ja auch
insofern weiter gucken das ganze kostet
ja auch eine ganze Menge und Krefeld
gehört leider nicht zu den Städten die
im Geld schwimmen zu den Kosten aber
macht die Stadt keine Angaben und obwohl
Krefeld direkt am rehein liegt wurde man
im Rathaus von den Themen Wasser und
Regenrückhaltebecken vollkommen
überrascht
Erklärungsversuche ne ich sehe kein
versäumis sich vielleicht an ein Stelle
intensiver noch mer austauschen müssen
ich glaub zu Beginn des Projektes war
nicht klar welche Wertigkeit auch das
Thema Wasser regenrückhalte Becken haben
könnte meine die starkringenereigise
letzten Jahre haben das Thema natürlich
noch mal ganz anders auch priorisiert
die Menschen in Krefeld sehen sehr wohl
planungsfusch also man sollte dann eher
mal vorher schon mal in den
Flächennutzungsplan reinschauen und
nicht so ein aprilschatz da draus zu
machen für jeden der irgendirgendein
Projekt hat geht's immer nach schemaf
und wenn ich das den er Punkt vergesse
ich kann den nicht einfach überspringen
und bei Z und 3 weitermachen das geht
nicht das kfelder leuchtturmprjekt muss
jetzt komplett neu geplant werden wann
die Bagger hier endlich anrollen kann
derzeit niemand verlässlich sagen